robots I'm alright alright I I wanted to
talk about this this actually I can
thank I can thank you folks I think my
father was my subscribers I forget where
I heard about love death and moms
monsters love death and robots first I
can't remember if it was on the council
of geeks discord available to patreon
supporters yes I'm getting the plug in
there early um or if it wasn't one of
the live chats every Tuesday boy I'm
getting that I'm getting a little scary
good at self-promotion anyways so what
love death and robots is it is a show
that's basically just a series of
animated shorts that's on Netflix I mean
you call them episodes but these are in
no way connected but it's not even
necessarily an anthology thing like in
the vein of something like black mirror
where it's similarly toned a lot of
recurring themes like that I mean there
are some recurring themes but like tone
is absolutely all over the place the
animation style change is that it's what
it did what it did that I loved was it
really does if you if you burn through
it if you binge it it captures the
feeling of going to a festival of short
animated films and I can say that
actually by being able to make the first
hang in comparison because when I when I
still lived in New York I went to the
animation show one year now the
animation show was a an animated short
film festival run by my judge of beavis
and butthead Fame along saw the things
and Don Hertzfeld who boy I don't even
know how to describe Don hurt spells
work and I really should talk about his
stuff one of these days because if it
connects with you it's amazing but it's
also really weird anyways they kind of
helped organize and spearhead this thing
that was that they called the animation
and I think I own a couple of
compilations of them from from various
years including the one that I went to
which I think got released as the
animations show vol 3 but it was all
these animated films in different styles
from different creators ranging in
length from you know like 30 seconds to
20 minutes and while the focus for love
death and robots is a little bit
narrower than that it is nice to just
find anything that taps into that vibe
again because I like I have a really
deep love of animation like long before
YouTube I was big into Newgrounds I
really dug well made short animated why
I honestly think that making a good
short that feels like a complete
experience is in many ways harder than
making a feature-length film it takes
less time but the thing is short films
at their best animated or live-action I
favor animated but both have to
establish everything that a
feature-length film film establishes
about your main character about what
they want about their obstacles about
the world that they're set in especially
if it's not set in the real world and
it's set anywhere fantastical which
pretty much all of these stories in this
series are and it has to establish all
that and bring it to a satisfying climax
in minutes without having an hour and a
half without having the room to have
exposition everything has to be
established quickly visually it requires
by its nature that you be lean and
direct and on point with everything you
do if you're gonna do it well and get
everything you need to get across and I
am in awe of filmmakers that can do that
and some of these entries and this
really do that incredibly well so I'm
not gonna go point for a point through
every animated short in this thing and
they their time
they range and I think this shorter ones
about eight minutes some of the longer
ones are around seventeen they largely
have a sci-fi bend to them which you
would expect from the title they're
largely dark they are often violent and
otherwise adult content II not all of
them are sci-fi there are a few that are
more Wow there's one that's like gothic
horror there's there's one that's like
it's a werewolf story and you know
that's kind of a an urban fantasy I say
that the setting is an urban but it's
that flavor of a story so it dabbles in
a little bit fantasy and a few things
that kind of you know straddle the line
between sci-fi and fantasy we just
something I generally appreciate because
I do like both and I and I would kind of
wish they played together more often as
much as they kind of get lumped together
like when talkies onerous so but the
overall vibe is generally not for kids
and with a sci-fi fantastical and often
horrific bent to it so that's the
overall vibe of the thing but again
individual ones will vary some are kind
and some go for scary some go for tragic
some go for funny some go for touching
some go for cathartic it it does run the
gamut I wish as much as it gave me that
feel of an animated festival
I wish there had been greater variety in
the animation styles there is a decent
mix but the vast majority of these are
CGI animated I think there's only a
couple that are traditional hand-drawn
2d animation on actually there might
only be one now that I think of it
because there's some of them that are
very much influenced you know designed
to evoke 2d but
pretty sure we're still done CGI so
there's that and but even taking that
into account even if we go okay so it's
motive it's almost entirely CGI but you
can still get varying visual styles with
that which is true you can but mmm a
pretty decent number of them go in for
the as close to photorealistic as we can
get look which for me honestly is one of
the least interesting things you can do
with animation because for me what it's
always been bizarre to me like ever
since I first saw the Final Fantasy the
the spirits within it struck me as
really weird that we that anyone was
trying to make CGI animation look that
realistic because if it looks that
realistic we'll just shoot it on film
you know what why are you even bothering
if you're not gonna add some kind of
artistic flair or some kind of
embellishment I you might as well just
do it with live actors so I've never
been a big fan like it's technically
impressive I'm not gonna claim it isn't
but I've never been a big fan of that as
an approach for animation and it can
work sometimes especially if like
everything else it is gonna have to be
created recreated as as CGI then okay if
you have one live-action element and a
sea of CGI that doesn't look right
either so like I'm not saying there's no
reason to do but I'm just saying overall
that's a that's an animation aesthetic I
don't love because I much rather see
something a little more stylized
something that leans into the fact that
it's animated a little bit more and so
the there is kind of that variance look
well let me talk about some of the ones
that really worked for me
I think the first one of the of this
season assuming that that there end up
being more which is called Sunny's edge
it was a good one to open with much in
the same way
at the national anthem was a good opener
for black mayor not necessarily because
like everything else is gonna be like
this but like this is your baseline this
is kind of the vibe of the thing as a
whole it is violent it is at points
sexualized it is very impressively
visually realized and it is harsh and I
I was actually very impressed with the
action in this one too there's there's
an action between these I don't even
know what to call them just these
creatures that is hard-hitting and
cathartic and kind of fist pounding and
I'm not gonna consider the support a
spoiler because like you start watching
it you'll catch on this really quick and
this happens a lot in shorts in general
especially sci-fi or horror ask shorts
most of them have some kind of twist at
the end because one of the advantages
that a feature-length film has is it
gives you enough time with these
characters to get invested in them that
you don't need like a twist at the end
to feel like oh there we go because with
the short you're with these characters
so briefly you can't necessarily count
on the audience having fallen in love
and been caring about them so buttoning
everything up on a twist is very common
again especially in sci-fi horror sort
of things which are genres that lend
themselves to twist so not everything in
this series has a twist but a fair
number of them do and I do think Sony's
edge lays things out well again in terms
of giving you a vibe for what you can
expect for how a lot of these things are
gonna go I think the second one of the
season though is my favorite of the
entire run which is just called three
robots and I found it to be the most
inventive from a writing and narrative
standpoint in terms of what it was doing
and also just the most enter
three robots is one of the funny ones
there's a there's a handful of them
they're not a lot them I know there's
like I don't know maybe three four you
could consider funny but three robots I
think is fantastic and it's just these
it's these three robots three very
different from each other robots
wandering through the post-apocalyptic
landscape or man once ruled but now has
been wiped out and like to them it's a
tourist destination they go wandering
around go oh there's that and with like
one of them obviously knows long he's
like yes and here was where they did it
and it's in the interactions between
them and the dynamic and it's kind of
ribbing each other over various things
it's really fun and it's really funny
and it was it was easily my favorite
piece um
then when the third one came up the
third one was the witness that was when
I started to get a little bit concerned
and that's gonna be aside from like the
the photo realistic animation thing
which again I'll grant is largely a
personal taste thing and it's not an
inherent fault in any of the shorts that
used it but I started to I started to
become very aware of the way in which
these shorts handle female characters
now I do kind of want to be careful
about how I talk about this cuz I like
my first thought after I finished it was
I can't be the only one who saw this
right and I look around I saw a lot of
very hyperbolic you know headlines why
does it seem like love death and robot
hates women am I like you know big
punchy headlines I'm like that no but
there is something a little bit off
because I'd say it's probably about half
of these and there's 18 all together
either depict
female characters in an overly
sexualized or in a way that they have
very severe violence committed against
them or both and it you know when I say
it's about half that may sound like I
mean is that that bad except that like
most of the ones where that isn't the
case a good chunk of those simply flat
out don't have female characters at all
and so you can't really be like well
they they gave us you know female
characters who weren't like that and
then even the yeah the ones that so the
ones that have female characters and
don't do that at all are definitely a
minority of episodes because most of us
that have female characters are doing
this is some extent and it varies it's
completely a case-by-case thing there
are some that like I said the witness
really brought my attention to it the
witness feels incredibly exploitative
which kind of annoying because it's kind
of like a really cool vibe to it
and and does some really interesting
things in terms of visual storytelling
but in some of the other ones you know
it's very much in passing you know
something like the dump or alternate
histories or when the yogurt took over
yeah there's one called when the ogre
took over it's very much a passing it's
like a fleeting joke it's like you know
a character looking at a porn magazine
that we get to see the interior of or
it's a one-off gag but that's still like
the entirety of the female presence in
the story is a brief bit of nudity and
it's I will refer back to a video I did
a little while ago which talked about
the problem being patterns because it's
not every single one of these individual
instances because some of them are all
things considered fairly and
he was some of them like like I said
like the witness arguably also Sony's
edge to a certain degree I I do part of
me wonders if I if I wouldn't have liked
that one as much if it came later in the
in the season after I'd kind of become
aware of watching for this maybe I
wouldn't have liked it as much I don't
know you know things like that it does
feel a little bit more baked into what
the the story is actually doing but
whether it's that or whether it's
innocuous the issue is how often it
happens because when something is
happening this regularly the the fact
that it is a pattern is in itself a
problem even if not every individual
instance is the worst offender in the
world or could even possibly be defended
on a narrative basis or what-have-you
so for something that is this short I
mean you say it's 18 episodes but like I
said they're all shorts it is a little
bit unsettling that this pattern is here
and I don't I don't know how planned
this was my instinct you know again
maybe I was being hopeful just because
of the the initial vibe of kind of a an
animation festival that I got off it was
that you know they had taken I don't
know proposals from various filmmakers
and go okay we'll do that one that one
that one or that one
I'm not sure that that was the case
though I didn't do a ton of research
into how was made but I did look over
the directors and there were a number of
repeat names which to me says this was
largely kind of coordinated and whether
or not there was a writers room or
what-have-you
it it doesn't the whole thing given its
similar theming and similar you know
recurrent animation styles like I said a
fair number of them do come back to that
same photorealism a lot of them are kind
of structured similarly it feels fairly
to live
which makes this the presence of this
pattern all a little bit more oh really
because I'm not sure they can say well
look it just kind of happened but even
if it did just kind of happen my
instinct would be it's people jumping in
too hard - oh we have so few
restrictions what push people's buttons
well sexual content and violence and you
know it's the same problem that I have
with the first season of Torchwood that
the second episode day one especially
it's just beating you over the head with
how adult
it is but it's adult elements are
completely sophomoric and most of the
individual episodes in this are not that
bad they're better constructed than that
but it does feel like the presentation
as a whole was leaning too hard into the
and we can kill people and we can show
boobs and we can have them say the
f-word and we're gonna do it am I is
there a reason do we have to do it
everything we can that's enough
[Music]
I'm not gonna say you can't you can but
like could there be a reason you know
and sometimes there is but not always
and not for as often as it happens I
want to get off the negative train and
touch on some some a few of the other
ones that I really liked I actually
really really liked suits which is that
one of the few I'd say probably that one
and lucky 13 that don't that have
prominent female characters that do not
feel exploited in some way because the
the others were female characters are
present but don't feel exploited they're
very much side characters you know
that's the that's the case in soul
sucker and and I've lost the name
whatever is the the kind of heist one
but what I really liked about suits was
I think it's the as much as it isn't my
favorite I think it is the one that that
exemplifies best what I talked about
about a shorts ability to tell a
complete story and set up a world and
give you a complete picture with no
exposition and get you to care about
characters in a really short amount of
time this does it like what suits is and
conceptually and visually easily could
have filled a movie but they they made a
short and it's a great short it I I was
really impressed with that one quite a
bit blind spot that was the highest one
and Zima blue I actually kind of liked I
I was worried at how pretentious that
was gonna be and I kind of even saw
where it was going I saw it coming but
it still hit the landing on Hoenn yeah
so despite my reservations and despite
you know things that I I feel like I
would have otherwise liked if they
weren't if they weren't in this pattern
like good hunting I feel like I would
have liked a lot more if I hadn't been
watching it in
connection with other things that were
giving me similar slightly skeevy
exploitative vibes I probably would have
liked it better in isolations so I feel
like lumping these things together in
some ways didn't do them favors I would
love to see Netflix continue this and
honestly I'd love to see them expand it
out to to other genres as well but if
they ever do this again I would like to
see them bury it up more just across the
board in terms of not always going for
the edge or you know head suck yo we got
to have one gruesome thing or you know
whatever so I feel like the this was
them doing all the stuff because they
could and I'd like to if they do it
again and see a little bit more
restraint and go okay look we could do
that but we did it for its own sake last
time if we're gonna do it let's have a
reason is there reason no okay well
let's do this instead then so I'd love
to see this get refined and feel a
little bit more purposeful for right now
though it's pretty fun and if you are a
fan of animation especially animated
shorts and you don't mind potentially
violent and occasionally sexually
exploitative content then I would
recommend checking this out actually
more so if you flat out enjoy that stuff
which some people do and that's fine I
what I complain about these patterns I
hope I never come across as like judging
the people who actually enjoy these
things or don't mind them or whatever
like that's fine I don't think you're a
bad person they just you know they
bother me and I wish to explain why so
that'll wrap up this one I think love
death and robots you seen it what did
you think about it what was your
favorite moment was your least favorite
would you think of the one random one
that was basically live action and had
Tove October Grayson
elizabeth winstead that was out of
nowhere it's pretty fun though whatever
your thoughts are jump something down in
the comments let's talk about a whole
bunch of stuff to do buttons links
patreon
feel free to support me there I'd
appreciate it links to other stuff
besides it's all down in the description
give it a look or don't because at the
end of the day folks you're the council
I'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]